[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
something's happening in britain state
schools we just a funding crisis which
teachers say is taking them to the brink
and shortchanging a generation of
children it's not rocket science these
children when they leave education and
not gonna have the same deal as those
that came before I've spent the week
looking at the issues facing heads their
staff and the children they teach my job
Security's on my mind all the time
I saw crumbling classrooms not fit for
the 21st century did drop luckily it hit
the side and didn't hit the class
teacher there you have a classroom full
of kids a teacher trying to teach and
the building is literally falling apart
around them
and parents caught between blind faith
and real worry I think where they're
gonna pull the money from but label it
from somewhere because the education
there they're the future out there the
government says schools have never been
so well-funded campaigners say that's a
lie
but in the 21st century but not back in
Victorian times so who's telling the
truth this is Tulane Infant School in
Sowerby bridge in Yorkshire zkk older
Valley its head teacher is Judy Shore
Judy tell me about tell me a bit about
the school school was built in 1879 it's
a huge Victorian building with an
enormous roof and grounds and a building
that just wasn't built for 21st century
education so to make it safe and
attractive and watertight costs us an
absolute bar - and our capital budget
quite often doesn't stretch to that so
we've patched up here when we've patched
up there and as it stands today it's
watertight the next layer that comes off
the roof we're going to really struggle
to by 2020 the government says core
school funding will rise to 40 3.5
billion pounds record levels but that's
not the full picture head teachers say
this whole funding crisis has come about
because they're being expected to pay
more than ever before national insurance
costs pensions maintenance of schools
and the amount of money they get per
pupil they say has not risen with
inflation all this at the same time as
the money they get coming in from
government has stagnated so a little bit
like a weekly shop where somebody used
to have 80 pounds and it covered it and
now the beginning at 85 pounds but those
goods are now costing 90 pounds and some
of the goods that they didn't used to
have to pay for they're now having to
pay for as well as some of the things
that used to always be there and I won't
available so there's been a huge amount
of change in terms of what schools are
paying out
and that the school gates they're
worried they don't get the same the
one-to-one as they need to especially
the starting to struggle a little bit
with something the state kids to one
teacher it's a lot and I wouldn't want
to be a teacher I was just putting
myself in that position just with two
children myself finding myself split
between two it's quite hard and I don't
think where they're gonna pull the money
from but need to pull it from somewhere
because the education there they're the
future aren't they
what if something goes wrong what if the
roof falls in and the can't pay for it
and then you know then you know children
need teachers and teaching assistants
and everything to look after them and if
they go with Innes there's not gonna be
much of a school and that's a very real
fear we're on our way to another school
just a few miles up the road in Hebden
Bridge the association of had teachers
say the government's own figures show
that a staggering 2.8 billion pounds has
been cut from schools budgets in the
last three years and we're about to see
the effect of that
Judy's taking me to meet Rachel Burton
head teacher at Riverside Junior School
in Hempton bridge
she's an ex police officer and she now
runs a school on a very tight budget
Tuesday and this is Nick man well I'm
making nice to see should we have a look
at some of the problems you've you've
got what you're about to see is the
reality faced by thousands of teachers
and their pupils in schools each day
okay
welcome to the school where the
classroom roof falls in came upstairs in
the class teacher was actually sat in
that corner at which point then I would
lump of concrete did draw luckily it hit
the side and didn't hit the class
teacher rachel says her budget is that
breaking point and it's taking its toll
on the school yes actually fell there
well mr. Taylor was up there because I
watched it so you sort of built this is
a false wall so to speak yes if you look
over here it's a false wall because all
of this is unsafe and safe there's a
cheap quick fix a wall was put up to
keep the kids safe because they were
learning about the Romans they called it
Hadrian's Wall to make the best of it
the children are still taught in here
that's come through again so it's
obviously with the rain starting again
room after room is damp or crumbling or
flaking we're now in the boys toilets
and unfortunately has been made secure
but on past occasions prior we've come
in and there's been bits of concrete in
the toilet and it's all the gable end of
this building because it's ornate type
cabling it all needs repointing and this
is where the cork gets changed and puts
a clothing on and things
this is the cooks you know annex to the
kitchen what's getting down and seeing
this especially it came down yeah
because it was obviously it has been
painted it's not very old the wood is
just literally coming away are you
that smiling yeah well you know but it's
not priority because these are the
timeless in developing but it's actually
requirement to have a toilet next to a
catering kitchen yep school in another
classroom water has trickled down onto
the electrics and this is appeared very
very recently you can see I knew that is
if these get very water heavy do you
feel no they just fall on the kids and
it could go fall on the kids so we have
to monitor and we have to change again
it's costing but you just pass you
spending money to patch things up this
the nightmare story being written across
the country modern Britain and it should
be better than this six hours a day of
children are spending learning in this
classroom interacting being busy the
staff are here they're not good enough
working conditions
there you have a classroom full of kids
a teacher trying to teach and the
building is literally falling apart
around them
[Music]
the community around Judy school is
struggling crime is rising in Sobe
bridge police numbers have been cut by
20% antisocial behavior is up by 1/5
and social services budgets have also
been cut we would certainly feel that
all the services so stretch that they
can't provide those services I'm sure
they would like to because schools are
the ones that day-in day-out see the
children and see the families I think
because of all those cuts because we see
the children day in day out we're trying
to hold everything together for them but
with increasing challenges and pulls on
our time and our resources you have to
pick up the pieces don't you all you see
a child go hungry or not have adequate
clothing and that isn't something that
any of us want to see happen and you're
not getting any more money for that
so the sums are adding up and if a child
needs specialist help and that's more
likely in deprived areas then the school
has to find the money schools have to
find the first six thousand pounds of
the funding for that as well and which
is obviously quite significant so if
you've got two or three children in a
school this size which is a very normal
number to have that's obviously twelve
thousand 18,000 pounds that has got to
be taken out of our budget that we don't
get any any extra money for whatsoever
so what's the alternative it's just not
funded it's just not funded yeah and
we've kind of got to muddle through
the Department for Education says it's
making funding for schools fairer as
well as offering advice to teachers on
how to save money schools are being
asked to do more and they have faced
some cost increases that other employers
are also facing such as employers
National Insurance Contributions the
standards are rising both in terms of
the proportion of schools judged good or
outstanding and the reading ability of
pupils young pupils is increasing and
we're helping schools to tackle some of
those extra costs particularly the non
staff cost ten billion pounds a year
we're helping them to buy computers and
energy and recruitment fees more cheaply
I'm meeting a local campaign group who
are fighting cuts in local schools here
suza former teacher Rob was ahead for
many years
and John still a government how long can
it go on for I don't know I think we're
in a crisis already I think we're
getting to a breaking point I'm sick to
death of hearing from Nick get about how
we can save on color photocopying and
turning the light bulbs are I speak to
head teachers who have got people
working in the dark from their own
choice because they want to actually
save on the electricity bills
I mean a state for first I needed a
speech therapist or educational
psychologist there and I contacted the
local authority and you know there they
were what what many feel all that
hateful do you well it it was provided
by the local authorities do so is it
fair to say that for all those years
their tech teachers went can I have this
yeah and it just arrived
what's that not just a little bit naive
that well the system can not sustain
that kind of can I have it yes you can
well I don't think so I mean because
what are we doing I mean we are
preparing today's children for
tomorrow's will for tomorrow's economy
we will see the problems that have come
out of this funding crisis in twenty
thirty years time some clever person
will say these problems now we've got 30
years down the road are down to what
this government did schools have for a
long time being at the center of their
communities
but many of those communities have
fundamentally changed they need the
schools as much as the schools need them
it's a fragile relationship if small
schools like this one were to disappear
from these communities they're going to
leave a great big hole there's actually
a lyric from a song that I find myself
saying over and over again and it's
there's a hole in my neighborhood down
whichever way I cannot help but fall and
that's how it's going to be
if it's all like this was too short you
worry that a lot of our families would
get lost in the system I always expected
to manage a budget but I didn't expect
to be doing his knocking posture off
walls or painting walls or you know
helping pop things up with my site
manager George is attack now and they're
only going to get tighter it's not
rocket science these children when they
leave education I'm not gonna have had
the same deal as those that came before
it's going to affect employment it's
going to affect training and I just
don't think it's fair it used to be a
job that people wants us to do
it feels like teachers and the
government are set on a collision course
in the middle children and their
education McMartin Sky News
[Music]